step outside those everyday behaviors
that perhaps aren't serving us right and
then to make real change I can come back
and suddenly happy is the man that
breathes in the morning right so it
could be right I I just sit and I just
do some breath work in bed even just
open my eyes instead of going right
there's my phone and checking in just
check in with yourself just breathe for
a moment down regulation start calm
you know and then try and remain calm
and I'd prefer even to rock up two
minutes late for something calm than I
would to be unregulated Mass it's the
everyday stuff it's the environment
stuff what can you take control of in
your everyday habitat in your everyday
environment because otherwise all that
work is just it's literally symptom
relief and you really need to get to the
cause of it you know yeah because we
might be going on running is the cause
or cycling on the bikes of course I
would say it's the stuff that you've
been doing for 10 or 15 hours a day that
isn't natural right then you go and try
and run with and try and cycle with yeah
that then compromises that chain